[Música]
casi todos los líderes del mundo se
reunieron cara a cara en la asamblea
general de la ONU por primera vez desde
que comenzó la pandemia de Kobe 19 el
debate general que comenzó el 20 de
septiembre e irá hasta el 26 se ha
concentrado en unos temas principales la
guerra en Ucrania sin duda ha sido la
gran protagonista al igual que la crisis
climática Por otra parte los países
latinoamericanos pusieron sobre la mesa
la lucha contra las drogas pidiendo que
se cambie la estrategia que se ha usado
históricamente y finalmente mientras que
Irán y Estados Unidos se lanzaron
críticas por el acuerdo nuclear que no
han renovado pero que tanto sirven las
declaraciones de los presidentes y los
cancilleres el sur global pide un nuevo
papel en la geopolítica mundial y que
cambia luego de esta asamblea de la ONU
estas y más respuestas las tenemos hoy
en el debate de France 24 yo soy María
Clara calle y para conversar sobre el
tema nos desde Río de Janeiro Mónica
hirs ella es profesora en el instituto
de estudios sociales y políticos de la
Universidad de Río de Janeiro y de la
universidad torcuato ditella desde
Bogotá también se conecta César niño
analista internacional de seguridad y
defensa y profesor de relaciones
internacionales en la universidad de La
Salle a nuestros televidentes les
recuerdo que también hacen parte de esta
conversación dejen todas sus preguntas y
comentarios en nuestras redes sociales
estamos en Twitter Instagram y Facebook
donde no se encuentran como arroba
France 24 raya al piso es y también en
mi cuenta personal
@mariaclaguirre la etiqueta para
conversar sobre este debate es numeral
el debate f24 y a YouTube pueden Seguir
nuestra señal en streaming también
saludamos a quienes nos escuchan en
nuestro podcast no olviden que todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y tuning para entrar en materia
quiero darle la bienvenida a Mónica y a
César nuestros invitados del día y
comenzando con Mónica para preguntarle
algo y es que en estos días hemos visto
unas participaciones que ya habíamos
escuchado por un lado Turquía pide
diálogo Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea culpan a Rusia de la guerra en
Ucrania los países bálticos exigieron
mayores sanciones contra Moscú Y aunque
el presidente ruso Vladimir Putin no
acudió directamente a la asamblea si se
pronunció anunciando la movilización de
más de 300.000 reservistas pero más allá
de todo esto Cuál es la utilidad de
estos pronunciamientos si el terreno la
guerra continúa
Bueno buenas noches
estoy pronunciamientos no no tiene
ningún poder y nunca tendrían para
frenar una guerra y principalmente una
guerra como esta
tienen o sea querían acá la posibilidad
de exponer Cuál son los roles que estos
actores que vos mencionas que tú
mencionas puedan tener o creen que
tienen en este el desarrollo del
conflicto
tú mencionas a Turquía Turquía es un
país que quiere
y trata y Busca un rol mediador es muy
difícil que Turquía lo pueda hacer solo
yo creo que acá hay un tema de
representatividad y obviamente y Turquía
tiene un digamos un lugar en la
geopolítica muy importante
tiene diálogo un buen diálogo cuando
como como
q tiene un obviamente miembros de la
octava o sea es un país que tiene
posibilidades de actuar Pero no solo yo
creo que esto es digamos sería y creo
que ahí justamente Turquía tiene que
sumarse a a un otro actor internacional
a otros para este generar un espacio de
diálogo entre los contrincantes No hay
ninguna duda de que este conflicto es un
conflicto que va a necesitar de
mediación
digamos tiene ya una larga duración
frente a lo que pensábamos y va a seguir
Sí y justamente como ha tenido una larga
duración Quiero preguntarle a César
nuestro segundo invitado qué tan
efectivo son estos discursos para que en
terreno cambie la situación que se vive
bueno para aclarar los los discursos
efectivamente son tal vez una ventana de
oportunidad para conocer las posturas de
los actores involucrados no obstante hay
un gran problema en todo esto y es que
estamos enfrentándonos y reconociendo
que hay una gran crisis asumida frente
al rol de las instituciones
internacionales no obstante No gracias
internacionales podemos condenar las
acciones por supuesto de un agresor en
esta oportunidad el caso de Vladimir
Putin sobre el derecho a existir de un
estado y de una nación como sería el
caso ucraniano de tal manera el caso de
Turquía el juego geopolítico como Mónica
lo advertido hace un rato seguramente
podríamos empezar a jugar una un rol
interesante en el escenario
internacional frente a las posiciones y
por supuesto frente a las perspectivas
de los actores globales en particular el
caso Turco pero también llama mucho la
atención el caso chino que tampoco se
presenta por supuesto en las Naciones
Unidas pero también manda su delegado yo
creo que aquí el asunto está o atraviesa
un poco por entender el entramado en el
cual creería yo que el asunto que
estamos viviendo hoy contemporáneamente
hablando es que el mundo está
desconcentrado hay muchas preocupaciones
al mismo tiempo y no hay un solo foco en
la agenda global y usted habla
precisamente de estas grandes ausencias
que son las de Putin y sigue pin pero
también Menciona un punto en el que
quiero que profundicemos y es la crisis
de los organismos internacionales como
la ONU de hecho la asamblea general ha
hecho dos votaciones en la que 140
naciones desde el inicio de la guerra
pidieron que separara la agresión y se
hiciera un alto al fuego Mónica usted
está de acuerdo con César en que esto
significa una crisis en organismos como
la ONU
bueno no hay ninguna duda que el
multilateralismo diferente a una grave
crisis es una grave crisis que está
relacionada a su propia principalmente
El Sistema Nacional unidas a la recámara
a su propia origen Naciones Unidas nació
como un proyecto
mundial este
y reúne la comunidad los miembros de la
comunidad internacional Pero ha sido muy
influenciado por un proyecto específico
de poder internacional que es el
proyecto liberal en un proceso un
proyecto de liberalismo internacional o
de internacionalismo liberal como lo
queríamos llamar y este es un proyecto
en este momento aquí enfrentar graves
dificultades este de legitimidad y de
fuerza de punto de vista de su propia
voz ahora también es cierto
que existen otros este espacios
multilaterales en lo que Nosotros
llamamos una guerra en geometría
variable y es muy llamativo que de los
países del brics el único que estuvo
presente fue Brasil y no por razones de
política internacional no presidente de
Brasil fue para ser política interna
Entonces digamos de hecho y digamos los
miembros del brics Son miembros
importantes este para decirlo de alguna
manera en el actual conflicto de Rusia
con Ucrania entonces llegamos acá Este
hay una crisis del sistema Naciones
Unidas hay una dificultad digamos de que
los países logren tener un espacio de
negociación y de de concertación yo
diría político diplomática y hay un
avance muy importante de la agenda
militar y estratégica propiamente dicha
yo me escuchaba a
Primer Ministro alemán no en los cambios
de la política exterior alemana son muy
muy este contundentes en los últimos
meses
y él digamos estaba ahí como decía César
proyectando poniendo en la en su voz
este la expresión de la política
exterior de su país que en este momento
sea militarizado profundamente Entonces
tenemos un contrasentido también porque
finalmente este las donaciones unidas y
la asamblea general han sido un espacio
de defensa de la paz y es una Paz Armada
en este momento este y mostrando sus
dientes no como Putin lo hizo hoy y esto
digamos es obviamente una una un
elemento de que genera mucha
incertidumbre miedo yo diría y digamos
fuerte de previsión de cómo esta
situación puede a Mónica y le quiero
preguntar también a César por un punto
que usted menciona y es el
internacionalismo liberal también
fracasando como lo vemos aquí en la
asamblea general a propósito de ese
internacionalismo liberal Rusia Putin En
su declaración habla en contra de lo que
considero una hegemonía sobre todo por
parte de Estados Unidos mientras que
Alemania con el canciller olafshalls
como ya lo decía Mónica y el presidente
francés Emanuel macú hablan de un
imperialismo Ruso queriendo conquistar
Ucrania César para usted entonces en
esta postura y en esta debacle del
internacionalismo liberal se puede
hablar de hegemonía occidental o de
imperialismo ruso Yo tampoco me
atrevería a matricular el mundo en dos
dimensiones como imperialismo o como
hegemonía liberal incluso no porque
podemos hablar también de una hegemonía
liberal yo me atrevería a decir que
efectivamente están en crisis las
narrativas y es una guerra también de
narrativas de posiciones en términos de
antagonismos y claramente de entender
que en efecto la alteridad en esta
oportunidad en las relaciones
internacionales actuales está tal vez
como una suerte de hostilidades y lo
llevo al punto en que las instituciones
internacionales que hoy digamos hacen
parte de nuestra gobernanza global son
instituciones que han sido desbordadas
por los fenómenos internacionales
tenemos un autócrata llamado Vladimir
Putin que ha empleado instrumentos del
siglo 18 en contextos del Siglo 21 y
esto Tal vez es lo que descoloca un poco
las digamos las misiones y por supuesto
los roles de instituciones como Naciones
Unidas Naciones Unidas Una institución
creada en 1945 con la conferencia de San
Francisco
que en últimas evoca tal vez a
preocupaciones del año 45 No ahí viene
otro llamado atención la crisis también
va por la
refundación tal vez de algunos de sus o
la capacidad de respuesta ante los
fenómenos internacionales entonces aquí
también es una suerte también de
entender que la discusión puede ser o
Estamos enfrentándonos a una gran
Primera Guerra global que efectivamente
el mundo no había enfrentado por lo
menos en los últimos 70 años y Aunque
ustedes no lo dice de manera explícita
si sugiere un poco que las instituciones
de la ONU se están desactualizando Y
esto nos da pie a nuestro siguiente tema
y es el Consejo de Seguridad que es el
máximo consejo y el máximo órgano de
Naciones Unidas que en teoría es quien
debe autorizar y tiene la única potestad
para autorizar o no una guerra cosa que
no vimos en Ucrania y de hecho este
consejo tiene cinco estados miembros
permanentes que son precisamente los
ganadores de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
Francia Estados Unidos Reino Unido Rusia
y por otra parte china ahora en esta
asamblea estamos viendo un llamado de
Estados Unidos incluso hay varios países
para que se agreguen países africanos y
de América Latina y el Caribe César
comenzando Usted cree que esta inclusión
ayudaría a transformar el Consejo de
Seguridad bueno varias cosas lo primero
para aclarar es que esta iniciativa no
es nueva no es del Siglo 21 ni del año
2022 esto ha sido incluso iniciativa de
algunos países incluyendo Brasil en una
época al inicio del Siglo 21 incluyendo
Japón en la propia Alemania no que
incitaron un poco la transformación del
Consejo de Seguridad yo creo que aquí
hay algo importante que entender y es
que si bien estamos aportas de observar
una obsolescencia casi que programada de
nuestras instituciones internacionales
es tal vez lo único que también nos
queda yo creo que también es la
ampliación del Consejo de Seguridad no
significa que resuelva los problemas
estructurales en los que efectivamente
podríamos estar todavía enfrentando a
que una nación decida el derecho a
existir de otra nación no significa que
porque se amplía el consejo de seguridad
en dado caso de que sea así que la
verdad lo dudo efectivamente por la su
propia naturaleza el consejo de
seguridad de Naciones Unidas a esto no
significaría tampoco un una una un
vuelco estratégico o un restablecimiento
de un estatuto de un equilibrio de poder
en términos de no agresiones futuras en
el sistema internacional actual yo me
atrevería a pensar que esto podría ser
más bien Una una suerte de equilibrio en
términos por supuesto de posiciones y de
repartición de algunas de las zonas más
estratégicas dentro de la propia
narrativa de Naciones Unidas pero no
creería que los problemas estructurales
se solucionen ampliando la porción y
perdona expresión y analogía la porción
de las de la torta en la repartición de
ese de ese poder en el Consejo de
Seguridad Mónica y usted comparte esta
postura o cree que esta ampliación del
Consejo de Seguridad permitiría que este
órgano viviera durante más años
Mira Acá hay varios temas y yo Estoy
totalmente de acuerdo con con lo que
dice César totalmente pero también lo
que quería sumar yo quería tomar dos
cosas acá una que
hace ya más de una década quizá 70 por
ciento de la agenda del Consejo de
Seguridad es África o sea en el sentido
de donde están los conflictos los
principales conflictos Kiss se manejan
desde Naciones Unidas donde desde el
consejo los mandatos de las misiones
etcétera etcétera y la representación de
África en el consejo Es realmente
yo no voy a decir ridícula pero
insuficiente Pero entonces la interrumpo
la interrumpo aquí con algo la
interrumpo aquí con algo Mónica y es si
la mayor parte de los conflictos ocurren
en África porque los africanos no tienen
un puesto fijo en el consejo de
seguridad
bueno sin tiene ni es rotativo lo que
pasa que no es suficiente son 53
naciones y tienen dos puestos este como
nosotros rotativamente la gestión este
yo quería llamar la atención de otra
cosa hoy día y tomando el tema de la
guerra este de Rusia contra Ucrania la
votad es un organismo mucho más
importante del consejo que el Consejo de
Seguridad Naciones Unidas la octava
Digamos como este un órgano este que
digamos donde se congregan este un
conjunto de países tiene mucho más poder
para decidir este Cómo esta guerra va a
seguir que amplíe su membresía como lo
estaba ampliando en este momento como
digamos una política digamos de
hostigamiento y obviamente de generación
de más desequilibrio en esta región este
que se incluya a a a a Suecia a partir
una negociación bilateral con Turquía de
la peor calidad humanitaria o sea
Tal vez sí entonces la inoperanza del
Consejo de Seguridad es una de las
grandes de los grandes problemas que y
la parte dejé representatividad es uno
de los grandes problemas que tenemos
pero hay campos de acción que están
digamos siendo utilizados en este
momento para grabar este conflicto
independientemente de las situaciones de
crisis humanitarias que este conflicto
está generando quiero que ahora
cambiamos de tema y hablemos de la
crisis climática porque Antonio
Gutiérrez el secretario general de la
ONU dijo que la crisis climática es un
paradigma de la injusticia moral y
económica y es que recordemos que entre
China Estados Unidos India y Rusia
producen poco más de la mitad de todo el
dióxido de carbono que contamina el
planeta César Cómo reciben estos países
entonces las posturas en contra de la
crisis climática y los señalamientos de
que es un paradigma de la injusticia
moral
bueno varias cosas Yo creo que aquí el
asunto también tiene que ver con la la
digamos la los raseros con los que se
está midiendo por supuesto los asuntos
climáticos Y es que en efecto la crisis
que acabamos de de discutir la crisis de
de de sobre Ucrania en la guerra
distrajo un poco la atención sobre un
asunto de carácter urgente en la
política global y tiene que ver por
supuesto con el cambio climático yo
insisten algo y es que si bien se invita
a que todos los países se comprometan
con lo que seguramente hemos llamado los
los los acuerdos incluso internacionales
Pues por supuesto Aquí hay una
responsabilidad aún mayor por parte de
las potencias que acabas de mencionar en
dos meses se celebrará la cop 27 si mal
no estoy en Egipto y esto generará tal
vez algún tipo de recomendaciones
nuevamente Pero siempre y cuando no la
recomendación es no sean lo
suficientemente puyantes o lo
suficientemente medulares efectivamente
esto no va a reconducir la geopolítica
climática incluso Estamos a una suerte
de unas grandes crisis no uno de los de
los veranos más duros en Europa aunque
los europeos dicen que puede ser el
verano más fresco porque los que vendrán
serán peores no la sequías las
migraciones climáticas estamos viendo
por supuesto por primera vez en la
historia no naciones y estados que se
están hundiendo en el Pacífico y que
están efectivamente teniendo que emigrar
de manera programada esta suerte de
problemas que si bien si pueden ser un
poco más silenciosos a que los ruidos de
las balas en Ucrania seguramente pueden
ser incluso aún más peligrosos en
términos de existencialismo si lo
queremos ver así yo creo que aquí a él
le pregunto para aclarar si me lo
permites es llamar atención sobre la
responsabilidad por supuesto de las
potencias que en últimas las potencias
seguirán siendo potencias gracias a su
responsabilidad con el medio ambiente y
Quiero preguntarle muy brevemente y
pedirle a Mónica que sea muy breve en su
respuesta Que se nos está acabando el
tiempo y es está paradoja o moral que
enfrentan estas potencias Pues por un
lado escuchamos en la asamblea general
que están en contra de la crisis
climática pero por el otro ante la
crisis energética muchas de las
potencias han aumentado su producción de
combustibles fósiles Cómo entender
entonces este doble discurso que vimos
en Nueva York
Cómo digamos la globalización de la
hipocresía es lo único que yo yo puedo
decir porque realmente no se entiende la
verdad es que no se entiende con las
señales que estamos recibiendo este del
ámbito
medioambiental las desastres que estamos
teniendo las este las altas y bajas
temperaturas que se siga jugando con
esto O sea yo estoy tú también si de
acuerdo con lo que decías César y
realmente es absolutamente
incomprensible que esto finamente llegue
a donde va a llegar y que se va a
militarizar Esto va a terminar siendo un
problema de seguridad mundial y lugar de
ser un problema amigo ambiental que
dependía del como decía César digamos de
un cambio de políticas de una educación
mundial y obviamente deje cursos este
colocados en el lugar correcto usted
habla de una globalización de la
hipocresía y esto me hace recordar un
poco el discurso que tuvo el presidente
colombiano Gustavo Petro
la asamblea de Naciones Unidas que
precisamente el criticaba la postura y
el doble rasero de atacar la hoja de
Coca Pero por otro lado aumentar los
combustibles fósiles que eran los que
iban a acabar la humanidad Le quiero
preguntar a César si discursos como el
de Petro que van un poco muy en la línea
con el que hizo Gabriel borich el
presidente chileno nos pueden mostrar
una nueva postura de los países
latinoamericanos pidiendo una entrada en
la hegemonía global yo creo que yo creo
que la la postura de los países
latinoamericanos en esta oportunidad
creo que tiene mucho que ver de un
pasado muy cercano recordemos que no
solamente el presidente Petro ha puesto
sobre la agenda la necesidad del cambio
discursivo narrativo y estratégico por
supuesto de la política antidrogas sino
también lo había hecho en su momento el
ex presidente Juan Manuel Santos en
Colombia también también lo había hecho
el expresidente Lula hace algunos años
pero también por supuesto recordemos
algunos de los discursos en el 83 de
Belisario También estuvo lleno de una
suerte de figuras literarias
interesantes en la en la en el discurso
de política exterior yo creo que aquí la
intención del presidente borich por
ejemplo de chile frente al llamamiento
de atención sobre dimensiones asociadas
por supuesto con el cambio climático con
el regreso de las democracias América
Latina con la discusión a propósito del
cambio climático y con la guerra en
todos sus niveles y el desplazamiento y
la migración irregular creo que son los
llamados de atención que América Latina
hace hoy por hoy no solamente por su
posición geopolítica sino también porque
es una zona altamente golpeada no
recordemos que la política mundial Es
solamente una cuestión de tensiones casi
que entre las potencias a veces América
Latina es un invitado de piedra en estas
discusiones y otra de las mayores
afectaciones es precisamente por el
narcotráfico y en la asamblea Colombia
Bolivia y Perú que son los tres
principales productores de hoja de coca
de todo el mundo coincidieron en hacer
un llamado para que se cambiara la lucha
contra las drogas sin embargo ni el
presidente Joe biden de Estados Unidos
ni los mandatarios que han hablado de
Europa se refirieron al tema Mónica cómo
entender eso silencios
este tiene mucha plata no este silencios
tiene que ver este con una situación
totalmente
establecida de que los de una visión de
mundo de que los problemas están en la
oferta
y no en la en la demanda de drogas y
esto ha sido así digamos en los últimos
40 años pongamos
y no va a cambiar no va a cambiar porque
ahí sí hay un consenso muy fuerte de que
el tipo de
condicionalidades presiones van a seguir
siendo del Norte hacia el sur y esto
digamos obviamente es muy problemático
porque no ayuda a que exista un cambio
de cultivo una nueva forma digamos
educacional educativa de lidiar con el
tema y claramente solamente un control
mayor en la este absorción en los
propios mercados de la droga en las
economías industrializadas Sí y antes de
pasar al siguiente tema muy brevemente
Le quiero preguntar a César por el caso
Venezuela Y es que la misión
independiente de la ONU publicó su
informe en el que por primera vez se
refiere directamente con nombre propio
del presidente Nicolás Maduro como uno
de los responsables de la represión
contra los opositores y también el
presidente paraguayo Mario abdo Benítez
insistió en que es necesario que el
Consejo de Seguridad siga investigando
el tema qué tan aislado entonces puede
quedar Venezuela luego de esta asamblea
bueno puede quedar aislado en términos
políticos pero es interesante observar
que no nos conviene a ninguno una
Venezuela aislada del sistema
internacional y eso eso puede ser
controversial lo que estoy diciendo pero
tiene tiene que ver con una razón lo
suficientemente estratégica y es que si
se aísla a Venezuela el sistema
internacional hay poca vigilancia sobre
Venezuela y habría poca por supuesto
control y veeduría sobre algunas de sus
de sus cuestiones ahora bien esto sería
interesante observarlo frente a cuál es
la capacidad o cuál es el tanque de
oxígeno que tiene la política a tanto
doméstica como exterior en términos de
Caracas para observar un poco también
las coaliciones en términos
internacionales
también por supuesto tendríamos que ver
un poco Cuál es el alcance esas
sanciones Y por supuesto su bloqueo si
Seguramente se da en términos más más de
largo plazo Ahora quiero que hablemos de
Irán el presidente de Brasil radiz y ya
hizo su pronunciamiento y en él mostró
un poco como la desigualdad de los temas
porque él afirmaba que su país solo
produce el 2% de la potencialidad para
construir armas nucleares tiene el 35%
de la revisión internacional y esto
coincide con un dato del instituto
internacional de paz de estocolmo
llamado y por sus siglas en inglés que
decía que la cantidad estimada de armas
nucleares que se desplegó que se
desplegaron en 2021 creció respecto a
2020 y que la mayoría de esas armas son
de Estados Unidos y de Rusia Mónica cómo
entender Entonces esta presión
contrairán en la asamblea general para
que firme el acuerdo nuclear para que no
produzca armas nucleares pero que las
grandes potencias nucleares sigan
desarrollando su Arsenal
bueno el tema de Irán Este es un tema
antiguo es un tema desde 2010 que está
digamos sobre la mesa va a la mesa Esa
sale de la mesa este tuvimos un momento
que parecía este estábamos muy cerca del
acuerdo lo que hizo Trump en su periodo
digamos de retirarse fue digamos él fue
de un daño enorme y por ahí y reparable
porque en Irán siempre hubieron este
segmentos a favor y otros en contra de
este acuerdo
hoy día va a ser muy difícil los
europeos realmente en este sentido
hicieron todo lo que podían para
mantener este acuerdo vigente pero solos
no podían y Estados Unidos ahora tiene
una visión muy ambigua esta afición no
está solo constituida por de la Casa
Blanca o el departamento de estado es
también una combinación de de Estados
Unidos con la relación bilateral con
Israel y en este caso digamos la
salvación Israel Irán son Siempre fueron
muy tensos desde que eran empezó a
llevar adelante su proyecto nuclear de
una manera general la no proliferación
está en Baja este y sí como las
declaraciones hoy de Putin solo
demostrar más aún esta esta constatación
o el pidieron más este fundamento
el pnp está y baja la no proliferación
está y bajas los países este a partir
digamos de los desarrollos de la guerra
Ucrania es muy probable que de una
manera general los proyectos nucleares
autóctonos para decirlo de alguna manera
se sientan con más legitimidad y
obviamente los seguimientos militares
domésticos en cada caso van a estarse
sintiendo más fortalecidos y cómo
entender César que por un lado se
presione a Irán para que firme el
acuerdo nuclear y por otro justamente
Rusia presione y un poco amenace a
occidente recordándole la gran capacidad
nuclear que tiene en caso tal de Que
decida intervenir en la guerra en
Ucrania yo creo que los países que
tienen en esta oportunidad Arsenal
nuclear están pensando más de dos veces
por supuesto su posible renuncia al
programa nuclear en términos militares
precisamente por lo que le pasó a
Ucrania frente al abandono del proyecto
nuclear con una suerte de protección por
parte de occidente y se dieron cuenta
que fue tal vez la carta blanca que
permitió que entre otras Rusia era lo
haciendo actualmente seguramente Irán
tiene también ese ese esa carta sobre su
agenda y sobre su mapa geopolítico y es
la suerte de seguridad negativa que no y
es la renuncia a un arma para generar
seguridad y confianza puede también
traer todo lo contrario unos dilemas
asimétricos de seguridad Así que en esta
oportunidad yo creo que aquí esta
lectura puede ser bastante peligrosa las
narrativas por supuesto aquí entender
que en una guerra una hipótesis una
hipotética guerra nuclear por supuesto
nadie saldría bien Librado lo tuvimos a
punto de conocerlo en el año 62 con la
crisis de los misiles en Cuba y Estados
Unidos pero también lo volvemos a
recordar por supuesto en los años 90 y
claramente actualmente seguramente la
preocupación aquí que podríamos ver Es
que la la tesis que lanza a la madrugada
de nosotros el presidente Putin puede
generar dos dos digamos aproximaciones
la primera un presidente decidido hacer
todo lo que sea por su política valor en
términos de eliminación del enemigo y la
segunda observar que de pronto es tal
vez la manera de mostrar una gran
debilidad suena paradójico Pero puede
ser una gran debilidad por parte del
presidente Putin lanzar una advertencia
nuevamente sobre su proyecto nuclear
sobre su espacio vital más cercano Bueno
ya miraremos qué tan real o no es esta
amenaza Y si realmente apunto no a esas
debilidades de las que nos habla César
ya para ir cerrando nuestro programa
Mónica quiero que usted nos dé sus
conclusiones sobre la asamblea general
de la ONU de manera panorámica Cuál es
la lectura que usted da de esto
Mire yo realmente para concluir creo que
es una asamblea que va a quedar en la
historia
no digamos tanto por haber digamos
encaminado gestiones pero por ser
realmente este una asamblea que puso la
agenda de dónde estamos y la verdad es
que todo digamos lo que se escuchó hasta
ahora o hasta hoy no estamos bien
hay mucha contundencia hay mucha
atención y hay bajísima capacidad de
concertación mundial y que se puede
esperar antes de esta baja capacidad de
concertación mundial
Mónica vamos con usted
la verdad que no la escuché qué se puede
esperar si hay baja concertación mundial
como usted lo dice
más tensión más tensión internacional
más desencuentro vamos a tener un
periodo muy difícil en la política
mundial es lo que yo puedo decir no hay
no no tengo Cómo poner esto de otra
manera César usted coincide con esto y
también coincide o no con que esta
asamblea nos muestra que lo que viene es
más difícil sí es efectivamente esa
asamblea es muestra tal vez de un
planeta en un estado de desconcentración
absurdo en una suerte de que los estados
no conocen bien Cuáles son los problemas
globales que cada uno sigue mirando su
propio ombligo en términos geopolíticos
y también por supuesto de entender que
es un diálogo A veces entre sordos y
este tipo de condiciones nos lleva a
entender que seguimos teniendo sobre la
mesa grandes asimetrías grandes
problemas globales poco digamos o se
avisó era una poca resolución de estos
problemas y conflictos y claramente nos
deja evidencias para Clara y es que los
fenómenos y los problemas globales
desbordan a las instituciones
internacionales y en ese diálogo de
sordos como usted lo llama cuál sería
Entonces el papel de los países
asiáticos africanos y latinoamericanos
pues efectivamente cumplir lo que
evidentemente pareciera ser una verdad
de perogrullo y es efectivamente
respetar el derecho internacional y yo
insisto con algo y es que por más de que
exista hoy una agresión militar por
ejemplo el caso de Rusia sobre Ucrania
no significa que no funcione el derecho
internacional no es como decir que es
porque exista el derecho penal no haya
criminales esto significa que el papel
de los del sur Global en términos de
África de Asia de América Latina
seguramente será llamar la atención
sobre los problemas trascendentales a la
agenda y por supuesto seguramente tener
un poco más de influencia en términos de
política internacional y de política
mundial bueno las dificultades que nos
muestra esta asamblea general de la ONU
además de la crisis del
internacionalismo liberal como ustedes
lo mencionaron Y de lo que Mónica llamó
la hipocresía globalizada sobre todo en
términos de medio ambiente Mónica hirs
Gracias por estar con nosotros en Flash
gracias a usted muy buenas noches y
César niño Gracias por acompañarnos a
ustedes Muchas gracias por la invitación
un placer conversar con Mónica y contigo
Gracias a ustedes y para nuestros
televidentes los invitamos a que sigan
conectados con France 24 porque en
segundos viene más información
internacional
[Música]